this is quite extraordinary dr tedros
the director general of the who convened
this emergency committee on thursday
they couldn't reach a consensus he as
you said decided to declare monkey pox
this public health emergency of
international concern anyway and it's
worth
understanding what that means it
basically means it's the highest level
of alert that the who can issue and it
means that this disease potentially
needs a global and coordinated response
now take a listen to what dr tedges said
were his reasons behind declaring it
we have an outbreak that has spread
around the world rapidly
through new models of transmission
about which we understand too little and
which meets the criteria in the
international health regulations
for all of these reasons
i have decided that the global monkey
box outbreak represents a public health
emergency of international concern
now at the moment dr teddrus said the
disease is concentrated among men who
have sex with men but it was very clear
that he and others uh or other who
experts were really keen for this to be
taken very seriously despite what slice
of society the illness currently affects
and the reason why it's concentrated
right now actually could make it easier
to contain with the right strategies
they said now globally at the moment
there are more than sixteen thousand
cases of monkey parks two thousand of
those just over that here in the uk but
there have thankfully been only five
deaths of all of them on the african
continent um the disease has been around
since the 1970s the main symptoms of
fatigue some
lesions on your skin and
kind of like flu-like symptoms that's
why it's somewhat difficult to
diagnose in its early stages but it's
also worth noting that the uk is rolling
out a system of vaccinations
targeting about 100 000 vaccines at
those people at risk and another
important point is that there is a
general consensus among scientists that
while this illness is worrying um it can
be dangerous for some people overall it
is a milder clinical picture than covid
and for most people it won't result in
death but still
worth
taking no taking caution the who really
taking it very seriously